these satellite images show silos
designed to house intercontinental
ballistic missiles or icbms according to
military analysts
hundreds have been constructed in
China's desert regions in the last
couple of years the launch pads are one
step in China's growth as a nuclear
force touted in footage broadcast by
Chinese State media and analysts say
they're getting closer to matching the
US's capabilities across land sea and
air both countries are unlikely to
deploy nuclear weapons but reaching
Triad capabilities enforces China's
strength as a nuclear power so we unpack
how the U.S and China's current nuclear
arsenals match up
since World War II the U.S has been
testing nuclear weapons this created a
decades-long lead on China but military
analysts and U.S officials say China's
capabilities are rapidly growing under
President Xi Jinping China currently has
an estimated inventory of 400 Warheads
but the Pentagon says it's on the path
to having as many as 1500 by 2035.
compare that to the US which has an
operational Warhead inventory restricted
to 1550.
and China's nuclear modernization
process involves more than increasing
the number of warheads the country is
also advancing the types of launchers in
all three Triad areas land-based systems
are key in that three-pronged nuclear
structure
for China it's the df-41 and ICBM which
defense analysts say could be deployed
in those silos the missiles can also be
launched from mobile systems and the US
military says China now has more
land-based launchers than the US
the df-41 is likely capable of carrying
three Warheads defense analysts say
using what's called a mirv system mirv
enables the weapons to deliver multiple
Warheads for different targets dropping
them at separate points along the same
trajectory and Chinese State officials
said the missile can travel up to 9 300
miles making it one of the longest range
weapons of its type in beijing's Arsenal
compare that with the US version the
Minuteman 3. the missile has a range of
over 6 000 miles it's also capable of
carrying three Warheads using mirv but
the U.S limits its systems to only
deploy one analysts say that China's
expansion on land is partly to do with
America's development of conventional or
non-nuclear weapons
the Americans have a military that is
increasingly emphasizing long-range
conventional Precision strike Hans
Christensen has been studying the status
of U.S nuclear weapons since the early
1980s those types of weapons that for
many targets can hold at risk targets
that previously needed nuclear warheads
to be held at risk and this is in fact a
serious concern for the Chinese and one
of the reasons I think that they are
building these large Silo Fields deep
inside China the Chinese government did
not respond to a wsj request for comment
on whether the building of the silos was
tied to American Military advancements
and a senior Chinese official would not
confirm the missile silos in comments to
State tv in 2022 however the official
did say the size of China's nuclear
force should not be estimated based on
satellite imagery
those silos also reveal a key issue with
land-based systems they're visible so
building nuclear missiles for submarines
or ssbns is a way to remain incognito
defense experts say beijing's current
underwater fleet has some crucial
vulnerabilities the Chinese nuclear
submarines widely believed to be much
noisier than American ones that's Dr
Tong Zhao he's been researching China's
nuclear weapons for more than 10 years
and that's where the significantly
undermine the overall survivability of
the Chinese submarines and therefore
undermines the overall credibility of
its sea-based inner care detergents
another crucial differentiator is how
far the missiles launched from the
vessels can travel take China's newest
gin-class submarine compared with the
latest us version the Ohio class this
submarine carries the Trident II missile
which can travel approximately
6480 nautical miles whereas China's
carries jl2 missiles which have a
shorter range of approximately 3 800
nautical miles the jl2 is sufficient for
China to Target Alaska Guam and Hawaii
from Waters near China some military
experts say but to hit U.S Mainland
targets beijing's vessels would need to
be deployed farther from China's Coast
into the Pacific where military experts
say the U.S has an advantage that's
because the US has placed anti-submarine
defenses in the Waterway limiting
China's ability to travel deep into the
waters they can go out and take all
sorts of positions on where they're
going to strike from how close are they
going to be to the Chinese Mainland but
China's ability to strike anywhere could
come together with the deployment of its
new jl3 system the Pentagon says it has
an estimated range of over 5400 nautical
miles and would for the first time place
the west coast of the U.S with
Incredible striking range of China
the last piece of a nuclear Triad status
capabilities in the air for China it may
come down to the H20 stealth strategic
bomber it's yet to be unveiled but in a
2022 report the Pentagon said the
aircraft would have a range of 6200
miles
this could help China to reach
previously out of range areas of the
Western Pacific including this U.S Basin
Guam it's unclear when the aircraft will
be ready for deployment
are they already fully operationally
deployed or are they still going through
testing and readjustments we don't know
in contrast the US has already released
new advancements in the air with this
B-21 stealth bomber unveiled in early
December this will be the first time
that the United States has long-range
nuclear cruise missiles on a stealth
bomb military analysts say the plane
helps to modernize the country's large
but aging Fleet even when the Chinese
get their bomber Force up to full snuff
it's still not a global Strike Force
like the American at all even with the
US ahead in the air China's growth is
likely to continue experts on world
nuclear Powers say that President XI
jinping's interest in expanding
beijing's nuclear Arsenal has increased
as China becomes an economic and
political rival to the U.S yeah hello is
there a Chinese able to catch up with
the United States in terms of
comprehensive National Power his
thinking is the more desperate the U.S
would become to contain China to make
trouble for China while it's extremely
unlikely either Nation will actually
deploy nuclear weapons the Pentagon has
said China's expanding nuclear stockpile
could negatively impact Global strategic
stability the prospects of U.S China war
over Taiwan or another
Regional flash points is much realistic
than before the Biden Administration has
attempted to reduce the threat of a
nuclear Conflict by pushing for arms
control talks with China but China has
rejected those overtures citing its
smaller inventory and saying the U.S
should reduce its stockpile first and
Military analysts note that China's
expansion also comes after Decades of
criticizing the United States and Soviet
Union for possessing nuclear Triad
status Chinese sees itself as a leading
international power
which deserves to possess the same
capabilities as the other nuclear major
powers
[Music]